great thanks so similar to commish's
first talk this morning both of the
talks are gonna be more like like class
lecture styles so we are gonna see some
complete proofs but not necessarily a
survey of many different results in this
area okay so the kinds of problems we're
gonna study are online selection
problems so the kinds of problems we're
thinking about are imagine you're trying
to hire a secretary or find a job or
select a life partner or something that
presumably you only want one of and so
how you might model this is that at
every time step secretary is gonna
arrive you're going to interview the
secretary and learn their value and then
you have to immediately and irrevocably
decide whether or not you want to hire
them okay and the reason this is hard is
because you can only hire one secretary
ok so just what a sample run might look
like is it is good so at time step one
Bulbasaur arrives and you decide you
know I don't have enough information yet
so you decide not to hire him but you
lose him forever and then a time step -
squirtle arrives and you also decide
that you're not happy with squirtle so
when you decide not to hire you lose it
forever and then at time step three
charter comes and you decide this is
okay and you decide to hire Charmander
but you don't get to see what else is
gonna come in the future okay so let me
before going into these two specific
models Stud ascribe an impossible
problem for you okay so let's say that
we decide to model this mathematically
in the following way so offline every
secretary is going to be assigned to
wait by some adversary and these weights
are unknown to you and then the
adversary is also going to choose an
ordering of the
it's okay and then online the
secretaries are revealed to you one at a
time and you'll earn their weight you
immediately in irrevocably decide
whether or not to hire them and your
goal is to maximize the probability of
selecting the max weight element okay so
it's not too hard to see that if this is
the model you're working in then the
best thing you can do is just high of a
random secretary and so the point is
that we don't actually learn anything
about like what are good algorithms to
do online selection problems so we have
to change something one way to change
the model is to take away the
adversaries power to choose an ordering
okay so maybe the adversary still
chooses the weights but the secretaries
are pre muted randomly before they're
revealed okay so this is called the
secretary problem and so here the okay
but online it's the same the secretaries
are revealed one at a time you learn
their weight you immediately and
irrevocably decide whether or not to
hire and your goal is to maximize the
probability of selecting the max weight
element okay so just to be clear a
sample run that might happen is here the
adversary has assigned these weights to
the secretaries and then a time step one
charmander comes and maybe you decide
that you don't want to hire so you throw
them away and then at time step two
bulbasaur comes and you decide he's
definitely not the max weight element
because he's not even as large as the
best we've seen so far and then maybe a
time step three Pikachu comes and you
decide that he's better than everything
you've seen so far so this is good okay
and then the point is still you don't
get to see what would have come in the
future how do you continue okay so
secretary problems are what we're gonna
study in the second half what we're
gonna study in this half are called
profit inequalities okay so here
basically the role of the randomization
in the adversary adversary are switched
so what's going to happen offline now is
that every secretary has a weight drawn
independently from some distribution and
the adversary gets to choose the
distributions and the ordering but the
distributions are known to you okay so
that's where you get some randomness
okay and online it's exactly the same
the secretaries are revealed one at a
time you immediately and irrevocably
decide whether or not to hire and now
your goal is to maximize the expected
weight of this
like development ok so again just to
give you just to be clear here's a one
sample run so maybe in this instance the
weights are drawn from these different
uniform distributions and in time step
one
Bulbasaur will be interviewed and you'll
learn that his weight is 5 you'll decide
that's not good enough you think you can
do better in the future there is no cost
to see more candidates but the only way
you get to see more candidates is if you
don't hire anyone so the cost is that
you don't get to go back at the
candidate who are better before for this
talk yeah it's going to be a finite
sequence and let's also say for this
talk you know how long the sequence is
so you know all of the you know how many
elements are and you know all the
distributions associated with them you
know that let's even say you'd know the
correct one yes I'll very briefly at the
end touch on you can change these
assumptions to say what if you don't
know what if the adversary gets to
change the ordering adaptively and some
of the results that I'm going to present
holding those models - yeah any other
questions
ok ok good so again going through this
example after you decide to turn down
Bulbasaur then you interview squirtle
and his value is 7 and you decide you
know what I think 7 is better than what
I can get if I continue interviewing so
you take squirtle and once you decide to
do this you no longer get to see what
weights actually would have come from
the secretaries in the future ok so
after this was a problem clear so I'm
gonna dive straight into some analysis
now
okay so the first thing that I want to
observe is that we can find the optimal
policy using backwards induction okay so
let's see what that looks like so if
somehow we find ourselves making it all
the way to Mewtwo without having hired a
secretary then definitely we should hire
him right because there's no there's
nothing we can possibly gain by waiting
okay so if we make it all the way to
Mewtwo we will hire him and we'll get
four and a half an expectation okay so
now we can reason if for some reason we
find ourselves making it all the way to
Pikachu we have two choices we can
either reject Pikachu and if we do that
then we'll get four and a half an
expectation from YouTube or we can
accept and we can get Pikachu's wait
okay so the best decision at this point
is to accept if Pikachu's weight exceeds
four and a half okay we can go back one
more step and say okay now if somehow we
find ourselves making it to Charmander
we can either reject and run the optimal
policy starting from Pikachu which gets
four point six to five in expectation or
we can accept and get charmander's wait
okay so we should accept only if
Charmander suede exceeds four point six
to five in this example it never will so
you will always reject him and you can
see how to continue this reasoning all
the way back to Bulbasaur and this will
tell you exactly what the optimal policy
is it's just a sequence of different
thresholds for each secretary you should
hire if they exceed their threshold and
reject otherwise in contrast to the
regular secretary programmer you goal is
to maximize the pour we want to maximize
the expected or the expected weight of
what we select yeah so the objective is
a little bit different
where did you get so this is conditioned
on starting from Pikachu if you run this
policy I'm just claiming it will happen
to be 4.65
yeah
okay
okay sorry so let me go back so okay so
we know what the optimal policy is and
so what questions do we still study well
just cuz we know what the optimal policy
is doesn't mean we know how well it does
okay so that's the first question and
this is kind of asking for a competitive
analysis so how well does this policy do
when compared to a profit so by a profit
I mean someone who knows all of the
weights every time they're sampled and
always picks the max weight element okay
so specifically does there exist some
number C such that for all instances the
gambler can get a C fraction of the
profits expected reward and the second
question is this dynamic program told us
to set different thresholds for each
element it's a reasonable question to
ask is it possible to get the same
competitive ratio by just setting a
single threshold for all the elements
okay and so here the main theorem is due
to seminal work of krinkle and Su
Cheston and follow up by some well Kahn
which shows that there is actually a
uniform threshold that guarantees half
of the profits reward and expectation
and this is the best competitive ratio
possible okay so I'm not claiming that
the uniform threshold is always optimal
because the dynamic program will often
tell you to use different thresholds but
if you just care about competitive ratio
then a half is the best you can get and
you can get that with a uniform
threshold okay so before so I'm going to
give you a complete proof of this but
let me show you what the tight example
is first okay so in this example there
are only two secretaries the bulbasaur
shows up first and his weight is
deterministically 1 and squirtle shows
up second and his weight is zero with
probability almost 1 in 1 over epsilon
with probability Epsilon okay so now
let's reason what does the profit get on
this example well they get 1 over
epsilon whenever squirtles value is high
and they get 1 whenever squirtles value
is 0 so they get 2 minus Epsilon and
what about the gambler the gamble has
two choices he can either accept
Bulbasaur and then he gets one for sure
or he can reject Bulbasaur
without knowing squirtles value so at
the time he decides to reject Bulbasaur
and take squirtle all he
knows that squirtles value is drawn from
this distribution which has an
expectation of 1 okay so no matter what
the gambler does he can't do better than
one okay so that's the tight example let
me now prove this okay so the threshold
we want to use is exactly the expected
reward of the profit over two so the
expected max weight element divided by
two and we're going to accept the first
element that exceeds this threshold okay
some notation for the proof I'm going to
use P to denote the probability that the
max weight element exceeds our threshold
and I'll use this alibi to denote the
contribution of element I to the
algorithm so this is the weight of
element I times the indicator that we
accept it okay and also just for
cleanliness I'll use this notation X
plus to be the max of a random variable
X in zero okay so I'm going to show you
a complete proof the math is somewhat
pedantic but I do want to go through the
whole thing the distributions of the
different ones could be different yes
you did not need correct you did not
need to know the permutation to decide
this threshold that's right okay so this
this first line is straightforward so
what are we going to do we're going to
decompose the expected reward of the
algorithm to just sum over every element
the contribution contribution of the
element to the algorithm and then all
we're gonna do is we're gonna take a guy
and we'll break up WI into WI minus T
and plus T okay so for the second line
will observe that T is a constant so the
expected value of T times summing over
all I this the expected value of this
indicator that the algorithm except sigh
is just going to give us T times the
probability that the algorithm accept
something okay so now we want to think
what is the probability that the
algorithm accept something well if one
of the elements has weight larger than T
the algorithm will accept something and
if the max is less than T the algorithm
will not accept anything okay so this
probability is exactly P
going to the next line we're just gonna
process what does it mean
for the algorithm to accept I what has
to happen well WI needs to exceed the
threshold and we need to have not
accepted anything before we got to
element I next we're just going to
observe that this indicator that WI is
larger than T if it's the case that this
is negative this indicator will be 0 if
it's the case that this is positive the
indicator will be 1 so this indicator
times WI minus T is just WI minus T plus
the max of WI minus T was 0 the next
step we're just going to observe that
whether or not you accept any element
before I is independent of WI because it
only has to do with the weights that
come before so I'm just going to replace
this indicator inside the expectation
with the probability and the last step
is we need to understand what is this
probability well it's at least 1 minus P
so why is this the probability that the
algorithm accepts anything and the
entire run is 1 minus P so the
probability that it accepts something
before it reaches I is uh sorry the
probably that it doesn't accept anything
in the entire run is 1 minus P so the
probability that it hasn't accepted
anything by the time it reaches I is at
least 1 minus P okay so this is not the
proof yet but this is the first step so
we've observed that the expected
performance of the algorithm is at least
P times our threshold T plus 1 minus P
times this sum which I'll refer to as
the surplus so this is kind of like the
expected sum of the weights
beyond what the threshold itself gets
okay and I also want to point out we
didn't actually use the choice of
threshold in this part of the proof yet
ok so this holds for any choice of
threshold you can get this guarantee
okay so that's step one the other thing
we need to do now we need to use this
and try and bound the expected max okay
so let's do this so this is again going
to be pretty pedantic but we'll start by
just upper bounding the expected max by
taking the max minus T and plus T okay
the expected value of T is exactly T and
this max over all weights minus T this
is the same thing as the max over all
weights of WI minus T okay the next step
we'll just observe this is a max over
all non-negative terms so we can upper
bound the max with a sum and now the
last step is observed that we've just
shown that the expected max is upper
bounded by this term T plus the surplus
so that means that the expected surplus
is at least the expected max minus T but
our choice of T was exactly the expected
max over two so that means that the
expected surplus is also at least the
expected max over two okay so what that
tells us is that both our choice of
threshold T is at least the expected max
over two and this expected surplus term
is at least the expected max over two
and so combined with the fact so the
rewarded the algorithm is P times
something that's at least the expected
max over two plus one minus P times
something that's at least the expected
max over 2 so we get at least the
expected max over two okay so then II so
I want to give a little bit of intuition
for what happened here but are there any
questions about this there is a non
correct yeah so it's so it's definitely
this is there's no way this is the
optimal algorithm for any instance but
if you just care about the competitive
ratio it does get you the optimal
competitive ratio does that make sense
except anybody probably how you could do
something about it correct you could you
could do something more clever but the
point is that if you choose to do
something more clever on many instances
it might help you but if you only care
about the
worst-case approximation ratio then it's
not going to do better than two yeah but
in practice of course you should do
something better than reject everything
is there another okay okay so let's okay
so what just happened so this a this
being able to lower bound what you get
with P times a threshold plus one minus
P times the surplus this holds for any
choice of threshold okay but B is what
let us get mileage out of a and the
point is that we have no control over
the value of P so if we want to get a
good bound from this observation then we
need both of these terms to be large so
I'd like to say that kind of what
happened was that on this threshold was
not too big so that the expected surplus
that what we get above the threshold was
still pretty large but it was also not
too small in the sense that the
threshold itself contributed a good
fraction of the expected max okay so
what happened was it this Rollins this
threshold I would say is balanced and
this isn't a formal definition yet but
we are going to see this idea more
throughout the talk okay okay so what we
just saw was a simple description of the
optimal stopping rule and we saw a tight
competitive analysis that happened to
also be achieved by uniform threshold
okay and so what we're gonna do in the
rest of the talk is we'll look at harder
versions of this problem so what if you
have multiple choices okay so what I
mean by that is that still every
secretary will have a weight drawn
independently from some distribution
that's known to you now the adversary
will choose these distributions and the
ordering and also some feasibility
constraints on which secretaries you can
simultaneously hire and I'll give you
some examples on the next slide okay but
these visibility constraints are also
known to you so now what happens online
the secretaries are still revealed one
at a time you still immediately in
irrevocably decide whether or not to
hire but now instead of only being
allowed to hire one secretary it must be
the case that the set of secretaries
you've hired so far has to be feasible
at all times okay and your goal is to
maximize the expected sum of weights
from the secretaries you hire
okay let me just give you some examples
of what these feasibility constraints
might look like so maybe you're trying
to fill K positions and it's feasible
for you to hire any set of K secretaries
okay or maybe you associate to every
secretary an edge in a graph and it's
feasible for you to hire any a cyclic
sub graph or maybe you associate each
secretary with a vector and a vector
space and it's feasible for you to hire
any linearly independent subset okay or
maybe you associate each secretary with
an edge in a bipartite graph and it's
feasible to hire any matching okay so
these are just examples of what these
feasibility constraints might look like
so here okay so what I want to
accomplish with this slide I'm not gonna
read through these results this is
mostly just to convince you that our
community has you know done a lot of
work recently on designing multiple
choice profit inequalities I'll leave it
up for a minute in case you want to read
through the results you can ask me
questions but while you're reading it
all it just define for you two terms the
first is a may trade so I would say that
a feasibility constraints for ma'am a
trade if it has the following two
properties
so first the feasibility constraint
should be downwards closed meaning that
every subset of a feasible set is also
feasible and second it has this property
such that whenever you have two feasible
sets and one is larger than the other
there is always some element of the
larger set that you can add to the
smaller set and maintain feasibility
okay so I think many of you are probably
comfortable with this but just in case
you're not you can think of feasible
sets as roughly corresponding to
linearly independent vectors in a vector
space okay and Maitre intersection is if
you give me a list of mate roids and say
that a set is feasible if and only if
it's feasible in every may trade
separately okay so for instance we know
that we can write bipartite matching as
an intersection of two mates we can
write 3d matchings as an intersection of
three mates okay so against I'm gonna
I'm not gonna talk in much detail about
most of these results
but what I want to do in the rest of the
talk is continue kind of hammering in
this concept of balance thresholds and
I'll do this first by giving you a
formal definition and then showing you
how to use this definition to get a to
approximation for K uniform 8 roids and
also to approximation for arbitrary
matrix okay and just remember the
high-level idea is we want to come up
with thresholds that are big enough so
that the thresholds themselves
contribute high weight but also small
enough so that the expected surplus
beyond these thresholds is still high
okay so now let me get into the first
part so I'm going to try and provide for
you a formal definition of what it means
for thresholds to be balanced okay and
to do this I need to introduce you know
one or two slides of notation so let me
get started with that so I'm just going
to use a opt to denote the max weight
feasible set and all I want to emphasize
here just to be really clear is that the
max weight feasible set depends on the
weights of the elements okay so for
different weights of the elements the
max weight feasible set will change and
so will its weight okay I will introduce
this term called the remainder of a set
H with respect to some weights is the
following let me read the English first
this is the best subset of opt that we
could have added to H and still remained
feasible okay so formally this is the
Mad Max over all subsets of opt such
that s Union H is still feasible of the
sum of the weights in s okay and I'll
give some examples in pictures after
this you can see what this looks like
and I'll define the cost to be
everything in opt that is not in the
remainder okay so you can think of this
as what we lose from opt by accepting H
okay and just to give you a heads up I
am going to abuse notation for the rest
of the talk I will use these three terms
to denote these three sets but I'll also
use them to denote their weight so I'm
going to write things like the expected
opt and the expected remainder what I
mean is the expected weight of these
sets
okay so let's see just some examples to
try and make these definitions clear
okay so let's say that sets of size 1
are feasible and here are the elements
and here are their weights then opt is
mu 2 and what's the remainder of
Charmander so this is the best element
of opt that we can add to Charmander and
still be feasible okay but we can't add
anything to a set of size 1 and still be
feasible because the feasibility
constraints are the only sets of size 1
ok so this means we can't actually add
anything from hopped to charmander so
the remainder is the empty set and the
cost is everything else so think of this
as by accepting Charmander we can no
longer accept you two ok if instead we
start from the empty set the remainder
is Mew 2 because we can add u 2 to the
empty set and still be feasible and the
cost is nothing because we don't lose
anything from opt by accepting nothing
ok if instead sets of size 2 are
feasible then opt is now Pikachu and Mew
2 okay so what's the remainder of
Charmander so again it's the best subset
of opt that we can add to Charmander and
still be feasible
so that's Mew 2 because this is the max
weight subset of size 1 so what is the
cost of Charmander it's everything else
so this is Pikachu and how you should
think of this is it by accepting
Charmander we can still accept YouTube
but we can't also accept Pikachu so
that's the cost ok similarly for the
empty set the remainder is Mew 2 and
Pikachu we can still add both of them
and be feasible and the cost is nothing
and if I have a set of size 2 Bulbasaur
squirtle then the remainder is the empty
set we cannot add anything to them and
still be feasible so the cost is the
entire opt ok so in general if sets of
size K are feasible so if it's a k
uniform a troy'd then the remainder of a
set H is the top k minus h elements of
opt because these we can still add to h
and be feasible and the cost are the
lowest h elements of the top K because
once we accept the set of size H
we can still get the top k- h elements
but we can't also get the lowest H okay
let me do one more example that's a
little bit more combinatorial and then
I'll move on from the definitions okay
so here's a example of a graphic mate
roid so feasible sets are a cyclic
sub-graphs
okay so in this example what is opt it's
the three black edges II D and C and so
we can ask what is the remainder of a so
it's the max weight subset of EDC that
we can add to a and still not have a
cycle okay so we can't add both E and D
to a because we would get a cycle so the
max weight subset we can add is e and C
so this is the remainder and the cost is
D okay similarly if we start with the
element E then we can't add E because
that would create a cycle if we have two
copies of the same edge so the remainder
is D and C and the cost is e and the
remainder of this set a B is e because
we can still add E and B feasible and
that causes us to lose DNC no because a
is not in the max weight basis yeah so
it's a property it's always elements of
opt are the only ones yeah okay during
it so this is the last so I'm gonna move
on from the definitions anyone else have
other questions let's assume that all
the weights are yeah distinct so that
opt is unique
okay okay okay so the last one so let me
just a formally define what is a
threshold inalca the it just defines a
threshold for every element I and maybe
these thresholds depend on the weights
of the previous elements okay so we
haven't seen examples of this yet but if
you're running an algorithm you could
set a higher or lower threshold for
element I depending on the weights you
saw so far okay and so I'm not gonna
write this the whole time but just
remember that thresholds can depend on
earlier elements okay so now here is a
formal definition of what it means for
thresholds to be balanced okay so a
threshold 'm has alpha balance
thresholds if whenever it accepts a set
h we have the following two guarantees
so first the thresholds are not too
small in the sense that the some of the
thresholds for all the elements we
accepted themselves cover a 1 over alpha
fraction of the expected cost and also
the thresholds are not too big in the
sense that the some of the thresholds
for any sorry let me say this first for
any set V that we could have added to H
and still been feasible the some of the
thresholds we used to reject the
elements in V is at most 1 minus 1 over
alpha times the expected remainder okay
and just to be clear when I say the
expected cost and the expected remainder
I mean with respect to fresh samples
drawn from the distributions completely
independent from the weights used to
select H ok so again I want to give you
a couple pictures just to make sure that
the definition is clear ok so what do I
mean when I say the expected cost and
the expected remainder so in this
example everyone's weights are drawn
uniformly from the interval 0 1 and
we'll say sets of size 1 are feasible so
the expected max weight element is 5/6
because there are 5 elements okay so
what is the expected remainder there
question ok so what is the expected
remainder of Charmander so we said the
remainder of Charmander is the empty set
so the expected weight of the empty set
is zero and what's the expected cost of
Charmander it's the expected weight of
the max weight element because that's
the cost of Charmander so it's going to
be five six okay and again so what's the
expected remainder of the empty yep
gentleman bill is good right so I so
that's good so that's why I mean so when
I said this is um the expectation is
with respect to fresh samples completely
completely fresh okay so what I mean is
so okay so again so formally what I mean
is that a Charmander as a for every time
I sample the weights
Charmander will have some cost and
remainder and I want to take the
expectation over re sampling so maybe
Charmander winds up being the remainder
of itself but I would take tormenters
weight in that case okay so that's
that's a good question so let me go back
so so I'm claiming that if you know how
you set the thresholds for the previous
weights then you also know how much room
there is left so all the information you
really need are these weights but in
principle you're also using this
information because you will know what
you accepted in the past yet
okay and similarly when we talk about
the expected remainder and cost of the
empty set the remainder of the empty set
is the max weight element so this is the
expected weight of the max weight
element and the cost of the empty set is
the empty set so this is the expected
weight of the empty set I'm getting a
bit confused Oh does not a deterministic
thing you correct how do you define the
cost and demeanor it correct so opt is a
random variable that is the max weight
element so here I'm saying on the so
what I mean formally by this is I the
set charmander is fixed then I randomly
sample weights I see what is opt then I
partition opt into cost and remainder
and I take the expected weight of this
okay yeah so I'm trying so I'm trying
hard to draw this connection between we
know that the expected hop is 5/6 and so
this is why we see you know five six
here it's because for every samples
we're recomputing opt and we're
recomputing the cost and remainder okay
so again let's see so what happens when
sets of size two are feasible then the
expected opt is five six plus two-thirds
the expected weight of the highest plus
the expected weight of the
second-highest okay let's go through the
same reasoning so if we have a set of
size 1 the remainder is the max weight
element so the expected remainder of
charmander is 5/6 and the expected the
cost of charmander is the second highest
element and the expected weight of the
second highest element is 2/3 okay and
then similarly the remainder of the
empty set is the entire opt which has
expected weight three halves and the
cost is zero and again if we start with
a set of size two the remainder is the
empty set so the expected weight is zero
and then here the cost is the entire opt
so the expected weight is three halves
okay so in general if you have the
feasibility that is sets of size K then
the expected remainder of H is the
expected weight of the top K minus H
elements and the expected cost of H is
the expected weight of the lowest H
elements from the top K
okay and again this top K and the lowest
H of the top K these are chosen after
you sample the weights okay so actually
before so are there any questions about
yes maybe it's moving away or it's a bit
from what you want to do but it seems
like a good property of an algorithm
would be that if the weights are iid
then the competitive ratio should go to
one and those thresholds I think if the
weights are oh you mean if you have more
and more more and more elements these
that's true so I'm not so again so I'm
not claiming that this is the best thing
to do I'm just claiming that if your
goal is to get the optimal competitive
ratio for non iid examples then then
this gets you the optimal competitive
ratio so I'm not I'm not claiming
anything beyond that yeah so in
particular it doesn't have the property
you just said and I'm not claiming
that's an undesirable property I'm just
I'm just claiming I'm focusing just on
getting the optimal competitive ratio
and nothing else is that does that
answer your question or not
it seems like it's going to be nice
because it would be easier to analyze
but the other end you lose a lot yeah so
I would say it gives you two things one
is it does give you a lower bound on how
bad the optimal policy can be so that's
one so that's I think the original
motivation for doing this analysis was
to understand what is a competitive
ratio of the optimal policy the other
thing it gives you is at least gives you
something you can do in the event that
it's difficult to find something better
so let me just be clear I'm not pushing
this as when you're faced with this
problem this is exactly what you should
do but I do think it's still worth I do
think it's still a very useful tool for
reasoning
I was trying to see if I could make some
sense I may not make any sense there
here's a thought right it would help to
remember that for matrix really a little
yes goes by looking at exactly whose
remainder yes
are you trying in some way to capture
some part of it yes definitely yeah yeah
so there'll be a roughly one slide about
that near the end but that's exactly
where these definitions come from yeah
yes so this intuition about the
remainder being the top and then the
clustered the next this isn't true of
agents like a set of heavy high
distributed elements and everything else
so yeah so just remember again that this
opt is taken after you sample the values
then you learn what opt is right and um
okay let me rephrase so let me say like
for K uniform eight roids you are
allowed to have two copies of charmander
that's fine that really it's just K you
know like multi sets of size less than K
or feasible if that helps does that
clarify your question so if H is a set
of highly distributed elements they can
be their own cost and remainder that's
fine no they can be that you can be your
own remainder that's fine I'm saying for
AK a uniform a troy I'm not adding a
constraint that says you can also only
have one Bulbasaur I'm just saying you
can have K Secretary's yeah does that
answer your question yeah
so just look I find you said that this
is a way or so to studies a competitive
ratio of the optimal policy correct true
is that obvious that you know we can
achieve the best configuration with
those strategies oh this is something
that will follow from so for one uniform
Maitre well one uniform eight roids yes
for arbitrary matrix also yes because it
turns out that thresholds like this can
get you a two approximation and you
can't do better than to form a troy
because you already can't do better than
two for a single choice okay so maybe a
better question is for K uniform eight
roids I don't think you can do better
than a constant with an approach like
this but you can as K grows get a ratio
that approaches one for K uniform so
that's maybe a good example that
separates the difference correct yeah
okay so let me now say okay so now I
spent all this time giving you a
definition let me at least use it for a
theorem so what we know is that if a
threshold Amalfitano this definition
then it guarantees a 1 over alpha
fraction of the expected op sorry it
gets a 1 over alpha fraction of the
expected opt okay so I'm not going to
give you a complete proof for this but I
will give you overview that captures the
salient ideas ok so what we can do is we
can write the expected value of a hopped
in the following way we can just take op
then partition it into the cost and
remainder okay and this is fine because
cost and remainder always partition opt
even if H itself is a random variable
for any choice of H this is just a
partition of opt ok in this not too
small guarantee immediately tells us
that just the expected sum of thresholds
from what we hire gets a 1 over alpha
fraction of the expected cost ok because
this is just reading off the definition
of not too small okay so this is where
it takes a little bit of work to see
this there's no way you can get this
just by reading but not too big
guarantee but it turns out that the not
too big also guarantees that the
expected surplus WI minus TI for the
elements we accept gets at least a 1
over alpha fraction of the remainder ok
and now when you sum both of these
together it directly tells you that the
expected sum of weights gets you the
expected oft over alpha ok ok so this
proves that coming up with balance
thresholds is useful now let's see if we
can come up with some okay so hold on
what's going on here ok sorry ok good
that is what I wanted to do so let's
observe that this threshold we used
earlier for one uniform matrix is
actually two balanced ok so this is
definitely a bigger hammer than we need
to get a two approximation for you one
uniform eight roids but let's go through
this anyway
okay so let's see if we can verify this
so if we hire anything the threshold we
use to hire it is exactly T the expected
max over two and what's the expected
cost of a set of size one was just the
expected max weight element okay and the
expected weight of the max weight
element is exactly twice our threshold
so this immediately gives us the not too
small
guarantee okay now let's reason about
the thresholds not being too big so if
we don't accept anything what are the V
that we can possibly add and still be
feasible it's any set of size one what
is the threshold that we would have used
to reject the element in V it's exactly
this and what's the expected remainder
of the empty set it's exactly the
expected max which is twice our
threshold okay so if we accept nothing
then the sum of this this sum of
thresholds will be exactly T and this
will be exactly two T over two which is
also T so it's good if instead we accept
something then the only V we can add and
so be feasible is the empty set so the
sum of thresholds will be zero and the
expected remainder will also be zero
okay so you immediately get not too big
as well
okay so now rather than just reprove
what we did earlier let me show you that
4k uniform ate roids you can also get to
balance thresholds okay so the threshold
we're going to use is the following so
for every element we'll look at the
expected opt divided by 2 K okay where K
is the rank ok so again to prove that
these thresholds are too balanced so
it'll fit all on one slide plus think so
what is the remainder of H we already
went through this so this is the highest
weight K minus H elements and what is
the cost
it's the h lowest weight items in the
top k so what does this mean so this
means that the expected remainder of H
is at least this so what is this so the
expected opt over K this is the average
weight of an element and opt and because
the remainder is the top K minus H
elements all of the average weight here
will be at least as large as the average
and there are K minus H of them what
about the expected cost we can use the
same reasoning the average weight of an
element in opt is opt over K there are H
elements and they're on average going to
be lower than the average okay so we get
both of these inequalities ok so now
let's see if we can prove that the
thresholds are not too small so if we
sum the thresholds for everything we
accept we're gonna get the following we
accept H elements each threshold is the
expected opt over to K and immediately
reading off what we have here we get
that this is at least the expected cost
over two so this tells you that the
thresholds are not too small similarly
if we look at any set of size V that we
could have added to H and still been
feasible the maximum size is K minus H
ok and what's the threshold that we
would have used to reject it's exactly
the expected opt over to K so the sum of
thresholds for any feasible set we could
have added is K minus H times the
expected opt over to K which by here is
it upper bounded by the expected
remainder over two okay so it directly
says that the thresholds are not too big
you
okay so this is a complete proof that
these thresholds are too balanced and
plugging into the previous theorem this
would give you a two approximation for K
uniform eight roids as well then your
threshold like how is this balanced
because they can't be there a remainder
so let me just define let me just define
the let me just assert that to find the
remainder so that you can be in your own
remainder so okay so formally let's say
that you have a two uniform a troy'd and
there's one element that has a very high
distribution and it's normally in the
max weight basis then for this element
the remainder is almost certainly going
to be itself and the cost would be the
other element of the max weight basis so
if you want a multiset with at most K
elements you would still kick something
out of opt it's not you get to add
yourself for free you still count twice
towards the K does that
maybe let me um let me just assert that
this is really the definition that you
want so if the more general definition I
gave is confusing really I mean when I
say remainder of h4k uniform eight roids
I mean the expected weight of the
highest k- h element so just stick with
this definition and if the previous one
is confusing forget about it also does
not use the order correct yeah you do
not need to assume that you know the
order that's correct
so actually now that enough people have
said it so I think none of the
algorithms that we'll see in this talk
actually use it you know the order let
me just say that there's maybe like a
subtle asterisk after that but it's
mostly true
okay so now before I go on to general
mate roads I want to prove the same
theorem again just to illustrate a
technique not not for any other reason
okay so what I want to do is show you
how you can prove that adaptive
thresholds are balanced okay so all we
saw so far
was it if the thresholds are fixed ahead
of time then how to show that they're
balanced but let's see how to do that
for adaptive thresholds as well
okay so here's one way to set adaptive
thresholds let me uh parse this first so
first this OP sub C is going to denote
the expected weight of the seethe
highest element
okay so op sub one is the expected max
weight element op sub two is he expected
second highest etc and I'll use this H
sub I minus one is the set of
secretaries that you hired from the
first I minus one so what is this
threshold it's basically saying while
you have accepted nothing then the
expected value of op sub K over two
that's your threshold and as soon as you
accept something the threshold goes up a
little bit now it goes up to the
expected value of op sub K minus one
over two and when you accept Keith you
know L things it'll go up to ops sub K
minus L over two okay so the thresholds
are adaptive depending on the weights
that come earlier yes oh this calculated
on all the you drop fresh samples and
calculate you know all the secretaries
including the correct correct
that's right yeah
okay so let's try and prove that these
adaptive thresholds are too balanced
okay so again let's remember the
remainder is the highest weight K minus
H elements and the cost are the lowest H
elements from the top K okay so the
expected remainder so now instead of
just bounding it let's write out exactly
what it is it's just the sum from C
equals 1 to K minus H of the expectation
of opsi okay because those are the
elements that are contained in the
remainder okay and what is the cost well
let's do the same thing I just chose to
write it in a little bit of a funny way
but again it's just summing everything
that's not included in this sum but is
in up so just something from C equals
zero to H minus 1 of op sub K minus C
okay so now let's try and reason that
these thresholds are balanced so first
we'll try and show they're not too small
so let's sum the thresholds for any set
we accept so what are the thresholds
gonna be what we said for the first
thing we accept the threshold is OP sub
K the expected value of op sub K over 2
for the second one it's op sub K minus 1
over 2 for the third one it's op sub K
minus 2 over 2 and so on so the sum of
thresholds that we used to accept these
elements is exactly this it sums from C
equals 0 to H minus 1 of ops of K minus
C over 2 and that happens to be exactly
the expected cost okay let's try and
show that the thresholds are not too big
so let's take any set of sy that we
could have added to H and still been
feasible so that set has size at most K
minus H how big could the thresholds
have possibly been when we chose to
reject them well it's definitely not
larger than the expected value of OP sub
k minus h but maybe it was even smaller
if the elements came earlier in the
algorithm and so what that means is that
the sum of thresholds for any set we
could add to H and still been feasible
is it most K minus H times the expected
opt sub K minus H over 2 and this is
upper bounded by the expected
/ - because this is K minus H terms that
are all op sub K minus H and this is K
minus H terms that are all at least that
big okay so here is so again this is
just to show you a technique how you can
prove that adaptive thresholds are
balanced as well okay so the last thing
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna state for
you the right balance thresholds -
you've use for general mate roads I'm
not gonna give a proof that these
thresholds work because that's a little
too much for the talk okay so here's the
thresholds you should use and these
happen to be two balanced for all
Metroid's okay so what is this this term
okay so H I minus 1 or the Secretary's
that you've already hired when you
process I so this is the expected cost
of H sub I minus 1 Union I so if you
were to accept I this would become your
new cost - the just the expected cost of
if you didn't accept I or / - so this is
kind of like the expected marginal cost
of adding element I to what you have so
far at least according to this specific
definition of cost okay so like I said
I'm not gonna prove that these work I
will just give you some intuition as to
where do these thresholds come from okay
so let's imagine two worlds in world a
all of the weights are gonna be redrawn
fresh the game is going to be restarted
except you've already hired secretaries
h i minus 1 and so there's limits the
secretaries that you can hire because
they have to be feasible when you add
them to H I minus 1 okay in world B same
thing all weights are redrawn fresh the
game is restarted but now you've already
hired secretaries H I minus 1 Union I so
you're even further restricted on who
you can hire ok so very clearly world a
is better and it's not obvious how to
see this from the definition of cost but
the definition happens to capture
exactly that if you are a profit then
world a is better by exactly the
expected marginal cost of adding i to h
i minus 1
okay so just intuitively what that kind
of means is it in order for you to
prefer entering world b/w I should be
competitive with its expected marginal
cost and the vite there's no good
intuition for why dividing by two is a
good idea that's what makes the math
work out okay does this make sense this
is just some intuition for why these
thresholds work and I'm claiming that
they get a two approximation for all
Metroid's non-adaptive to balance I
think for general mate roads there is no
uniform threshold that gets a constant
factor approximation I do not know if
there is a non adaptive but asymmetric
thresholds I definitely don't know that
they exist I also don't know that
they've been ruled out
okay okay so that's the end of
everything
technical let's just recap what we saw
so far in the whole talk okay so I tried
to just hammer in this concept of
balance thresholds and the main idea was
it you wanted to say that the thresholds
were not too small so that the
thresholds themselves cover some
fraction of opt but also the thresholds
were not too big so that the expected
surplus beyond the thresholds was also
large okay and I want to point out that
there are other different there are
different ways to reason about balance
thresholds and so another one here's
intuitively what they would sound like
is you would like thresholds to be not
too small so that you're unlikely to
block any specific element from being
infeasible to accept but you'd also like
them to be not too big so that you
accept enough elements and expectation
okay right so if you have thresholds
that are very if you have thresholds
that are very small and you just accept
a lot of things right away then many
elements they're never going to be
feasible for you to accept so this seems
like a bad idea but also if your
thresholds are so large that you just
don't accept anything most of the time
then this also seems like a bad idea so
there is a way to formally reason about
this - I don't have time to discuss more
this connection I'll just point out that
there there's a tool called online
contention resolution schemes and this
kind of reasoning is very related to
this okay and just to be clear I'm not
claiming that all proofs related to
profit and equalities follow this
methodology and in fact you you know we
know for K uniform 8 roids this
methodology I don't think will give you
the optimal competitive ratio but I do
think it's a good way to think about the
challenge of profit and equalities okay
it's trying to come up with thresholds
that are not too big and not too small
okay and the last thing I want to do is
just very quickly survey some results in
slightly different models so what if you
get to choose the order of the elements
instead of having the adversary choose
the order then you can actually improve
the to approximation to e over e minus 1
and this is due to a result of yan from
xi
and I will state the algorithm but I
will not say anything about the proof
other than this one sentence okay so
what the algorithm does is it just
computes for every element what is the
probability that you were in the max
weight basis and then it finds a
threshold such that the probability that
you exceed that threshold is exactly
this Qi okay then you sort the elements
in decreasing order of Ti so this is why
you need to be able to choose the
ordering and then you just hire every
secretary that's feasible subject to
being larger than its threshold okay and
like so so all I'm gonna say about the
proof is just to give you this buzz word
that the main tool use are called
correlation gap inequalities good
question so if the so if instead the
order is random then we know that for
the single choice problem so for one
uniform eight rhoids you can also
improve the two to an e over e minus one
but we don't know beyond the single
choice problem yet for random order but
with distributions okay
another question so maybe there's a
little bit subtle and I slipped it past
you but if you wanted to use the the
thresholds for the mate road profit
inequality you do need to compute you
know some pretty intense expectations
every time you process a new element
okay so and this is certainly possible
to do if you have the right access to
the distributions but a reasonable
question to ask is what if you don't
have the right access and you only get
access to samples okay so we do know
that for K uniform mate Royds with only
one sample from each distribution you
can still get an asymptotically optimal
algorithm but this is just a cute
question that I don't know the answer to
which is what is the best competitive
ratio you can get for the one uniform
problem with one sample from each
distribution okay so all I know is that
a reasonable thing to do is to set the
highest element you see in your samples
as a threshold and it's not too hard to
show that this gets a for approximation
with some more work you can show it does
better than for but I don't know what
the
what ratio exactly this algorithm gets
or if there's anything more clever and
definitely I have no idea how to get a
constant factor approximation for all
mate roids with just a single sample
from each distribution okay okay one
last comment so what if an adversary
adaptively chooses the ordering so what
if it's more powerful than what we saw
on the last slide so basically every
result in this talk holds even if the
adversary knows the weights exactly so
if the adversary is a prophet it knows
exactly the weights and then gets to
mess with your algorithm the exception
is again the may trade profitably Rees
but not quite so powerful so if the
adversary is adaptive but it doesn't
know the future then the may trade
profit in topology holds but we don't
know if it holds against this profit
adversary okay and the last comment is
one of the reasons that our community
has been doing a ton of work on multiple
choice profit inequalities in the last
few years is because there's kind of a
generic reduction from designing good
profit inequalities against appropriate
adversaries and these immediately imply
good mechanisms in certain bayesian
settings and I think Anna's gonna talk
on Friday more about this okay so this
is everything I have for the first half
thanks a lot for listening
thank you for the ride no more but I
think for the maple fun we have
something but something is slightly
better than you should be okay nice
problem we can say about the profit
secretary minimization version of this
problem because we try to maximize the
things I mean you can't just do exactly
all of this with minimization and
hearing the same people be sure that I
should be not suffering in my vision
that is the natural version does not
work you may need to change see me
minimization but you're forced to accept
something you need to choose one
essentially yes I also didn't mean to
say that this is an exhaustive list of
other problems related to profit
inequalities that are studied so that's
a good one too the minimization so
that's a good question I was actually so
I thought it was tight someone caught me
like right before the talk and told me
that they think it's not tight so it is
tight for the correlation gap inequality
so the proof technique can prove
provably the proof technique is not
going to get better than a / t minus 1
but I'm not positive that that for this
problem a / u minus 1 is tight
so I missed our discussion that so what
a juggle mate right if you have not
finish words can you get constructive so
it's it's I don't know I also don't know
that they've been ruled out so I do know
that with a uniform threshold you cannot
get a constant factor approximation but
maybe with not adaptive but asymmetric
thresholds you can I just don't know how
to do it I also don't know that it's
been ruled out